you know I could never fall asleep at
night because I'm always just so wired
hey guys it is Monday you're in its
grace yep I went on my tumblr - guys
what did you want to see me do for this
Monday video and so many of you wanted
me to react to the official Fifty Shades
of Grey movie trailer one shade of beige
is the name of my memoir I have not read
Fifty Shades of Grey
I barely know what it's about
middle-aged woman in heat I assume so
let's watch this trailer laptop I'm
sorry for what I'm about to do to you
it's two and a half minutes well no
wonder she likes him even lasts a long
time is that even relevant what is this
thing about let's just do it
that's my Wi-Fi here is very bad so
might stop just like nevermind Universal
Focus Features oh she seems so sad but
she's got bangs you're gonna hate this
bang soon mr. gray that girl does not
work in a business like that
she's an actress I think they're both
actresses she's he's smart he knows how
to unbutton his jacket boy did some what
sex this seems like sexual harassment
she's not confident he is
your success I have two sides control
little things he's still he's a robot
this Valentine's Day to set camp Takota
whoa they kissed an elevator
he's a sex addict what he's in a jet
they're both in a jet is that a metaphor
now he's got no shirt on again she's sad
they're gonna do weird sex Oh
this took a turn
okay it started very Devil Wears Prada
different gendered boss and I was like
oh I thought I was a middle-aged woman
that has like a sex to a dude that oh
I'm feeling things Oh No why did they
give her bangs you know it's a it's a
myself in her I mean what my reaction is
that it seemed like nothing and then all
of a sudden you bring her to a sex
dungeon then what happens where's the
conflict she becomes a nymphomaniac then
what happens do they raise an army of
nymphomaniacs what happens
where are the stakes and not like the
but stakes that you put in your butt I
don't know I don't know if sex toys so I
watch porn alone when you can watch it
together with a bunch of strangers in
their late forties I'm just gonna watch
the end part one more time well you got
to stop now post and participate in my
graces guidebook handwritten letter
contest I will be announcing the winners
over on my tumblr so make sure you go to
grace Helbig to my comm and find out who
won who gets letters from these digits
everything feels gross now that I watch
that trailer everything feels perverted